se reunieron en julio con el presidente
de Estados Unidos Joe biden en un
acercamiento con riad y el príncipe
heredero Mohamed Bin salman esa relación
tiene un sin sabor ahora Washington está
enojado tras la decisión de la semana
pasada del cartel de la OPEP liderados
por Arabia y sus aliados por Rusia la
llamada OPEP más de recortar la
producción de petróleo en dos millones
de barriles diarios en un intento de
aumentar los precios la Casa Blanca dice
ahora que reevaluará los vínculos con
Arabia Saudita a la luz de los recientes
acontecimientos y de las decisiones de
la OPEP más sobre la producción de
petróleo el presidente cree que
deberíamos revisar la relación bilateral
con Arabia Saudita y echar un vistazo
para ver si esa relación está donde
debería estar y que esté sirviendo a
nuestros intereses de seguridad nacional
informa que Arabia Saudita desafió las
advertencias de Estados Unidos real
desestimó a los funcionarios
estadounidenses que dijeron que la
reducción de la producción sería
percibida como una toma de partido por
Rusia en un nuevo golpe a las relaciones
Vladimir Putin que se reunió con el
presidente de los emiratos árabes Unidos
El jeque Mohamed Bin sayet al nayan en
San Petersburgo dijo que las acciones de
la OPEP más eran simplemente para crear
estabilidad en el mercado
conozco su posición nuestras acciones
nuestras decisiones no están dirigidas
contra nadie no lo hacemos para crear
problemas a nadie nuestras acciones
están dirigidas a crear estabilidad en
los mercados energéticos mundiales
el desaire de la OPEP aparte de ser
visto como una ufetada diplomática hace
tener un aumento de los precios en las
gasolineras el recorte de la producción
comenzará el mes que viene el aumento de
los precios mundiales Aquí ya está
causando enormes problemas a los
gobiernos y consumidores de todo el
mundo